>>You see now, you could
draw a little mouse.
>>Narrator: Most schools
have computer labs
where students come a few
periods a week to do homework
and polish their digital skills.
But EAST labs are different.
EAST stands for environment and
spatial technology and in labs
like this one at Horace Mann Middle
School in Little Rock, Arkansas,
students spend five periods
a week and countless hours
after school designing buildings.
>>If you put a door,
I guess, right here.
>>Narrator: Making films.
>>Play it from there.
>>Narrator: And dreaming
up ambitious projects
that they see through to fruition.
>>I made a model based
on a greenhouse outside.
>>Rick: I tell them the first
day, this is not a computer class,
this is a problem solving class
in which you take a community service
project that may be very well an idea
and you make it a reality.
Not pie in the sky, make it happen.
Believe that you can do it,
and that really opens a lot
of doors for these kids.
>>Narrator: To participate in
the nonprofit EAST initiative,
schools need to raise about one
hundred and fifty thousand dollars,
which covers the cost of technology
tools and ongoing teacher training.
>>Turn it to the side
so like they can look.
>>Narrator: Many EAST projects
have an environmental theme.
>>Adiba: Our project is
the bird sanctuary project
and students can come out
during their lunchtime
and during their class
time to observe the birds.
>>We can just like
move it down, can't we?
>>Yeah.
>>Adiba: The average teenager only
goes outside twenty minutes a week,
and this project hopefully will
help kids learn about nature
and appreciate the birds [inaudible].
>>Rick: I don't select
the projects for them.
They buy into those projects
because they believe in them.
>>We contacted the people
who own the rights--
>>Rick: They want to
make a difference.
They have been told for the
past ten, twelve years that,
"You're too little, you're
too young, you can't do it."
And then all of a sudden,
you say, "Yes, you can do it.
Give me a plan, find the money."
And these kids are
very inventive about it
and they become very passionate
about what their cause is.
>>Justin: We're actually
designing a stadium to go
out where our football field is.
Hopefully, they'll actually come
up with enough money to build it.
Right now, it's gonna cost really
expensive, 'cause we've come up to
where it's gonna be
turf versus grass.
And then the popcorn and everything.
>>Popcorn?
>>Popcorn, that's important.
>>To raise money for the school.
>>Yeah.
>>Narrator: One project
began as an effort
to document a dark chapter
in American history.
>>Rick: The Japanese American
internment project started
out as a very simple idea and the
idea was to find the two camps
that existed in south
Arkansas and GPS them.
>>Student: This is the camp.
All around it are cotton fields.
All I'm trying to do
is put things on a map
so people can tell
there's history lying just
so far away, just that far.
>>Rick: What ultimately happened
is, these kids became so passionate
about what had occurred that
they wanted to make the citizens
of Arkansas aware of what had
happened in their own backyard.
So it became a documentary film.
That documentary film came about
because they figured out a way to go
to California and interview
Japanese Americans.
>>Man: You know, like I always say,
the wound has healed
but the scar remains.
And it remains as a reminder that
this should never, ever happen again.
>>Narrator: More than
thirteen hundred copies
of the student film have
been distributed worldwide,
and the production
led to the creation
of a memorial garden at the school.
>>Lauren: It made me more serious
about what changes kids can do
and that we can actually make an
impact, and people will listen to us.
>>Teacher: What we're looking for
now is ideas from students on how--
>>Narrator: Students also make
an impact on their community
through service learning projects.
Working with the local
Audubon Society,
Mann students surveyed the
Fourche Creek watershed adjacent
to their school.
>>Rick: The number one goal of
this particular project would be
to really get students to tune in to
their environment, where we're able
to literally take down the four
walls of the science classroom
and put students out in the field,
where they're doing real
world data collection.
>>Nineteen point nine.
>>Neelam: We are testing the water
quality for dissolved oxygen,
turbidity, fluorite and
a coupla other things.
>>Student: The temperature in the
air is twenty-nine point nine.
Temperature in the water,
about twenty-one point six.
>>Mary: So many of the students
that we work with in rural,
urban and suburban areas
do not get outside.
Their only knowledge of
nature is based on television
and so it's a very superficial.
Sometimes when we go out, they
think they're gonna see monkeys,
and they will say things like,
"I've never had my tennis
shoes off concrete,"
or "I didn't know birds made sound,"
which to me is such a travesty,
because Arkansas is an
incredibly blessed state.
>>Neelam: Well, I like
learning about the environment
because it's something
that has a lot to do
with our lives and the way we live.
And I hope to become a
pediatric radiologist,
and if that doesn't
work out, I was thinking
about being an environmentalist.
>>Narrator: Horace Mann
students presented a video
of the Fourche Creek project
and showed off their other work
at the annual EAST conference, where
more than two thousand students
and facilitators from around the
county come to attend workshops...
>>-- use a drawing program, you
should know what layers are--
>>Narrator: Present projects
and compete for awards.
>>Mary: We do have a medallion for
each one of the finalist winners
to symbolize and remind
them of the environment
that they have worked to protect.
>>Narrator: It's a rock concert
atmosphere in which hard work,
imagination and community
service are celebrated.
>>David: The critical element
of EAST is the subset of skills
that EAST kids are developing
as a result of their projects.
It's not to say their
projects aren't important.
They are very important, but the
skills are absolutely primary
and these are the skills that are
today being called twenty first
century skills.
You look at the communication skills,
at how personable these kids are,
how well they interact
with grown ups.
>>Around here is La Jaima and that
site is a little warmer as well.
>>David: Their problem solving
skills, tolerance for ambiguity,
their sense of being able to do
things that they didn't even know
where possible, those are
amazingly important skills,
and that to me is the
underpinning of this whole program.
When kids leave EAST, they
are prepared for the world.
>>Rick: What does it feel
like to be out like this?
>>Nice.
>>Very cool.
>>Rick: Think this is a
place that you could learn?
>>All: Yes.
>>Narrator: For more
information on what works
in public education,
go to Edutopia.org